Alright guys so in this lecture we are going to talk about entry patterns. So there are two entry
patterns that I use for my entries regardless of what strategy that I'm using. So I could be
using ABC and I'd be using those entry patterns. I could be using the under over pattern strategy,
I could be using ABCD. Well for ABCD you don't really need to see the market structure shift but
if you look for market structure shift on ABCD as well it can work out greatly as well. So what
are entry patterns right? So let's assume that you have a POI right here. So this is your POI and
there is one called the inducement. So let me just put this the inducement entry pattern
and then there is BOS liquidity pattern right. So these two patterns work pretty well. So let's
assume that you have a POI right. So this box right here is a POI. So this is inducement right. So let
me just put this. So price is coming back into your POI and it just reverses before you entapping
into your POI. Now what does it say? It's like calling in early buyers right. So this is like
manipulation. So what when people are going to see that the price is growing up from this level
they are going to form or end. They're going to buy here, here, here and here right because they
think that this the price has found the bottom. In reality this is liquidity being generated by
the market makers okay. So one price so the people will have their stop losses below this level
and there will be breakout artists right as well. We're going to take trades when this level breaks.
So price comes back into the POI actual POI and then it goes back up. So this is an inducement
entry pattern that you can use with every single strategy okay. Whether it's ABC, whether it's
any other okay. Whether it's auto flow it works perfectly well. So you see you have inducement
right. This is our POI price comes back into a POI and you would have taken your entry here
and boom it goes up. Now we have the BOS liquidity pattern and what is it.
So you have your POI right. So price comes into your POI right and then you have a change of
character or market structure shift and when you have change of protector right you would have
your auto block here at the extreme zone right. So you want to take your entry from the extreme
auto block. So you have marked out your extreme favorite auto block plus favorite gap.
If price without tapping in goes up and breaks another structure like this. So this is break of
structure or market structure break right. This is market structure break and we have this
fairly gap with auto block and price never came back here and before it came back here it made a
another higher high. Now a lot of people will take their entry from this level considering that
this is a break of structure right. So a lot of people they will take their entry from here. However
they fail to notice that this right here is liquidity okay. So price is going to come back
down into the lower time oh into the POI right not the lower time from but the POI and it's
going to go boom like this. So remember this pattern okay. Now price can actually do something
like this as well. So let me just draw this out delete this out and delete this out as well.
So price can actually come back and before price shifts the market structure or before market
structure shift happens price can actually create a break of structure liquidity pattern right.
So this is perfectly fine as well. So yes you have a change of architecture here or market
structure shift here but price also had a break of structure. So your entry would be valid
from this level as well. It's not necessary for price to
shift the market structure and then break the structure right. No when even if price hasn't
you know shifted the market it can create a break of structure pattern which is which
is going to look something like this right. So you have a break of structure and you also have
change of structure here and that is absolutely fine as well because this is liquidity level.
So make sure you know that and when price comes back into your POI
come boom it's going to go up like that. So these are two entry patterns and I have explained
these entry patterns in one of my YouTube videos so please refer to in detail okay. I have
you know explained this in detail by showing examples on YouTube so I don't think it's
necessary for me to you know just repeat the same thing in the course as well. You can go to my
YouTube channel I'll actually link it in this video description so you can watch it on the YouTube.
So these are simple entry patterns that you can use so in every strategy right. So
yeah guys I'll see you in the next lecture.